MARK.
>> Marc: HERE WE GO,
THAT.
I RISING OFF THE THE ON THE FAR
SIDE ITAHEAD.
SO
DANGEROUS.
>> Marc: HERE IS
YEAR, EVERYBODY CONTRIBUTED
THE DEFENSIVE SIDE AND GOTTHEY O
7 AND 8 AVAILABLE DEFENSEMANNOT
THEY COME BACK THE JUST
PULLING HIS WAY THROUGH
IN EAR
>> Marc: GOALIES NOWADAYS
CREATIVITY, IMAGINATION IN THE
COME INTO THE NEUTRA
POST, TWO POSTS BY THEGOAL,
EVERYBODY AROUND ME, GIVE YOUR
HAND THE REST RICOCHETS INTO TH
TIME WITHPASS.
GOT CU
TEAM THAT WE REALLY LIKE THEY
GET THEIR DOWN 7TH OF THE SEASO
>> Peter: YOU ARE RIGHT,
LOGAN O'CONNORSHOT, SCORE! OFF !
IT'S A POWER PLAY GOAL HE GOT P
JERSEY DEVILS THOUGHT THEY HAD
THEIR STICKS IN THE PA BACK
FOR TEEN-4-1.ND
OUT, COULDN'T
GET IT QUITE ACROSS WAS GOING B
LOOKING.
HE THE
STRANGEST SEQUENCES HAMMOND IS
LEAVING, NO ONE IS LOOKING AT